♪
>> Laura: THE LEFT TURNS ON
LATINOS, THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
ALL RIGHT, WE PREDICTED THIS,
THAT THE LEFT WOULD REALLY TURN
ON HISPANICS.
>> HOW CAN THE DEMOCRATS BE SO
IGNORANT AND SO SMUG AT THE SAME
TIME?
THEY LITERALLY CANNOT FATHOM
THAT LATINO VOTERS ACTUALLY
THINK FOR THEMSELVES.
THE TRUTH IS, THE LIBERALS DON'T
REALLY LIKE YOU.
THEY JUST USE YOU AND THEY TALK
DOWN TO YOU EVERY SINGLE
CAMPAIGN SEASON.
THEY THINK YOU'RE STUPID.
WE THINK YOU'RE SMART.
>> AND LIKE CLOCK WORK IT ALL
TRANSPIRED.
THE RECENT SAGA BETWEEN -- BEGAN
WHEN TAPES LEAKED ON HISPANICS
DEMOCRATS IN THE LA CITY COUNCIL
USING RACIST LANGUAGE INCLUDING
THE WORD FOR MONKEY WHEN
SPEAKING ABOUT AFRICAN
AMERICANS.
>> IT'S THE BLACK AND BROWN ON
THE SLOPE AND THEN WHITE GUYS
WITH THEIR LITTLE BLACK KIDS,
THE KIDS BOUNCING OFF THE F'ING
WALLS.
THERE'S NOTHING YOU CAN DO TO
CONTROL HIM.
[BLEEP]
>> Laura: AND NOW THE REGIME
MEDIA, RATHER THAN FOCUSING ON
THE INDIVIDUAL LIBERALS WHO USED
THE OFFENSIVE LANGUAGE, RATHER
THAN HIGHLIGHTING THEIR
SHAMELESS HYPOCRISY, WELL,
INSTEAD THEY'RE JUMPING TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT ANTI BLACK
SENTIMENT IS SYSTEMIC AMONG ALL
LATINOS.
>> THE REALITY IS, THERE IS A
LOT OF ANTI BLACK RACISM THAT
EXISTS ACROSS ALL ASPECTS OF OUR
SOCIETY INCLUDING WITHIN THE
HISPANIC COMMUNITY.
>> Laura: REMEMBER, THE PEOPLE
USING THE RACIST LANGUAGE THAT
WE PLAYED EARLIER ARE DEMOCRATS.
A FACT TOTALLY GLOSSED OVER BY
MINNESOTA REGIME MEDIA TYPES
INCLUDING AT CNN.
>> THERE IS BLATANT
DISCRIMINATION AND RACISM BUT
THERE'S ALSO THIS CASUAL RACISM.
I COME FROM THE LATINO COMMUNITY
AND I HEAR, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
BEING REFERRED TO AS THE LITTLE
DARKY.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT WE AS A
COMMUNITY DON'T ADDRESS ENOUGH.
>> Laura: NOW, A BUNCH OF ANGRY
LIBERALS RUNNING CITY GOVERNMENT
IN LA USING RACIST LANGUAGE AND
NOW THE ENTIRE LATINO COMMUNITY
NEEDS REEDUCATING?
THIS IS COMPLETELY BIZARRE.
YET, OF COURSE, TOTALLY
PREDICTABLE.
DEMOCRATS ARE INCAPABLE AFTER
ALL OF LOOKING THEMSELVES IN THE
MIRROR AND ADMITTING THAT THEY
HAVE A PROBLEM.
NOW, BEYOND ISSUES OF BIGOTRY,
IT'S THE POLICIES, STUPID.
THE POLICIES THAT HAVE CAUSED
REAL PAIN AND REAL SUFFERING FOR
WORKING FAMILIES, INCLUDING OUR
FASTEST GROWING DEMOGRAPHIC
GROUP VOTING BLOCK HISPANICS.
ALL BECAUSE OF BIDEN, ALLING
BECAUSE OF THE DEMOCRATS THAT
VOTED FOR HIS RADICAL AGENDA.
AND WHILE THE MEDIA ARE DOING
THEIR BEST TO FORM THIS
PROTECTIVE COCOON AROUND HIM,
THINGS ARE SO BAD THEY CAN'T
HELP BUT DO SOME REAL REPORTING
ONCE IN A WHILE.
AFTER ALL FACTS ARE STUBBORN
THINGS AREN'T THEY?
ACCORDING TO AN ANALYSIS BY
WELLS FARGO AND THE BANK OF
RESERVE NEW YORK, HISPANIC
LATINO AMERICANS EXPERIENCED THE
HIGHEST INFLATION RATE OF ANY
GROUP OF AMERICANS.
AND BACK IN MAY REUTERS SPOKE TO
35 HISPANIC VOTERS IN TWO
TOSS-UP RACE ARIZONA AND
COLORADO, 20 OF THEM SAID THAT
SOARING INFLATION IS THE CAUSING
THEM TO SERIOUSLY CONSIDER
VOTING REPUBLICAN.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
THE E ELECTRIC TORT SIC ATE
SWING TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IS THIS A SWING WE CAN EXPECT TO
CONTINUE.
>> IT WILL CONTINUE.
AT TIMES LIKE THESE IT'S REALLY
ECONOMIC CONCERNS THAT TAKE
PRIOR TO.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IS
THE HISPANIC COMMUNITY IS
DEALING WITH, YOU KNOW, HIGH
INTEREST RATES, ENERGY COSTS,
RECORD HIGH INFLATION AND
HISTORICALLY IT'S BEEN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT FOCUSES ON
THOSE ECONOMIC ISSUES.
>> Laura: YOU BET.
AND DEMOCRATS I THINK THEY KNOW
THEY'RE IN DEEP DO DO HERE.
A NEW POLL OUT TODAY SHOWS THAT
LATINOS SUPPORT FOR THE GOP IS
SURGING OVER THE PAST FOUR YEARS
ALONE, UP A WHOOPING 10 POINTS
AND OH BOY IS THIS MAKING
LIBERALS ANGRY.
CHARLES BLOW HARD AT THE NEW
YORK TIMES WRITING, I HAVE A
THEORY ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
AMERICA THAT I DON'T WANT TO
COME TRUE.
THAT WITH THE BROWNING OF
AMERICA, WHITE SUPREMACY COULD
SIMPLY BE REPLACED BY A FORM OF
LIGHT SUPREMACY IN WHICH FAIRER
SKINNED PEOPLE PERPETUATE A
MODIFIED ANTI BLACKNESS.
MODIFIED ANTI BLACKNESS?
REALLY?
IS THIS THE BEST ARGUMENT THEY
HAVE NOW?
SO IMAGINE, YOU'RE AN HISPANIC
ENTREPRENEUR.
YOU KNOW, YOUR ENTIRE FAMILY HAS
WORKED DOUBLE SHIFTS TO MAKE A
BETTER LIFE FOR THEMSELVES.
MAYBE YOU STARTED A CONSTRUCTION
COMPANY OR RUN A CHAIN OF
RESTAURANTS.
AND YOU WAKE UP ONE DAY AND YOU
SEE THAT ALL YOUR PEOPLE ARE
BEING SMEARED AS THEY WERE BY
CHARLES BLOW THERE, JUST BECAUSE
OF WHO YOU ARE.
BY DEMOCRATS NO LESS.
THIS IS CRAVEN AND IT'S CYNICAL
AND FRANKLY, IT'S SICK.
EVERY DEMOCRAT CANDIDATE OUT
THERE SHOULD BE ASKED IF HE OR
SHE AGREES WITH THE CHARGE THAT
HISPANICS ARE CULTURAL RACIST.
I THINK THIS IS A HUGE POLITICAL
MISCALCULATION.
BECAUSE RATHER THAN FIGURING OUT
HOW TO TURN AROUND OUR ECONOMIC
DECLINE, DEMOCRATS ARE JUST
TURNING ON THEIR OWN
CONSTITUENTS.
AND IF THEY CONTINUE TO TURN OFF
THE LATINO VOTE, AND IF
REPUBLICANS DO WHAT IS
NECESSARY -- NOW THIS IS A BIG
IF.
BUT IF REPUBLICANS DO WHAT IS
NECESSARY TO MAKE AMERICA
PROSPEROUS AND SAFE AGAIN, MAN,
THIS COULD LEAD TO GOP DOMINANCE
FOR DECADES TO COME.
OH, AND I'M GOING TO MAKE
ANOTHER PREDICTION TONIGHT.
HISPANICS AREN'T THE LAST GROUP
THAT THE DEMOCRATS WILL TARGET
OUT OF THEIR OWN POLITICAL
FRUSTRATION.
MUSLIMS MAY BE NEXT.
>> WE'RE NOT GUESS ANYBODY.
WE'RE NOT AGAINST HOMOSEXUALITY
WE ALL HAVE OUR BELIEF BUT THIS
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT.
WE'RE HERE JUST TO TALK ABOUT
THE VOTES AND THE PORNOGRAPHY
INSIDE THESE BOOKS.
>> THE RIGHTS OF CHILDREN.
>> Laura: OBVIOUSLY CHALLENGING
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR SCHOOLS
IN MICHIGAN.
IF MUSLIM AMERICANS CONTINUE TO
CHALLENGE THE TRANS AGENDA IN
THEIR STATES, IF THEY DARE TO
SPEAK OUT ON CAMERA, NO LESS,
SHOW UP AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS, SHOW THE COURAGE OF
THEIR OWN CONVICTIONS, THEY WILL
BE THE NEXT GROUP SMEARED.
YOU SEE WHERE ALL THIS IS GOING.
DEMOCRATS CAN BALANCEIZING THEIR
OWN VOTER BASE.
YEARS FROM NOW THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY MAY FIND ITSELF UP MADE UP
OF ONLY, I DON'T KNOW, WOMEN
LIKE THIS.
>> PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STAT